>> Tucker: MEGYN KELLY WAS A
FIXTURE AT FOX.
IN EARLY 2017, SHE MOVED NBC
WERE AMONG MANY OTHER THINGS SHE
ANCHORED THE THIRD HOUR OF
"THE TODAY SHOW."
IT TURNED OUT TO BE A TURBULENT
YEAR.
EXECUTIVE CAUGHT COVERING UP FOR
Q6 CRIMINAL HARVEY WEINSTEIN.
THE NETWORK’S MOST FAMOUS
ANCHOR, MATT LAUER, FOR THE
BUILDING AFTER HE WAS IMPLICATED
IN A LAUNDRY LIST OF MISDEEDS.
AN AWFUL LOT OF DRAMA FOR ONE
NETWORK.
MEGYN KELLY WAS RIGHT THERE TO
SEE ALL OF IT.
SHE LEFT HER SHOW LAST OCTOBER.
SHE HAS NOT DONE A SINGLE
TELEVISED INTERVIEW SINCE.
WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE HER ON THE
SET TONIGHT.
MEGYN, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
>> Tucker: THE RONAN FARROW
BOOK ADDS DETAILS TO WHAT WE
ESSENTIALLY KNEW WHICH IS THAT
NBC EXECUTIVES, PRACTICALLY HEAD
OF NBC NEWS, COVERED UP FOR
HARVEY WEINSTEIN.
HERE’S WHAT RONAN FARROW’S BOOK
SAYS.
I WANT YOUR REACTION TO THIS
QUOTE.
"PHARAOH BRINGS A RECORDING BY
THE NYPD TO NBC AND AN EIGHT
HARVEY WEINSTEIN ADMITS THAT HE
ABUSED AN ITALIAN MODEL.
ON TAPE.
NO OFF CHAIM RESPONDS "MY VIEW
IS THAT THE TAPE AND HARVEY
WEINSTEIN GRABBING A LADIES A
COUPLE YEARS AGO, THAT’S NOT
NATIONAL NEWS.
"DOES THAT SURPRISE YOU, HAVING
WORKED THERE?
BECAUSE NOTHING SURPRISES ME
ANYMORE.
IN THIS INDUSTRY.
AS I WATCHED THE RONAN STORY
UNFOLD, THE ONE THING I WANTED
TO KNOW IS WHAT DID THEY KNOW
AND WHEN DID THEY KNOW IT.
I’VE BEEN REPORTING ON THE STORE
EVEN WHILE I WAS AT NBC.
I TALKED TO RONAN.
I TALKED TO HIS PRODUCER, I
TALKED TO ROSE McGOWAN.
I TALKED TO MANY HARVEY
WEINSTEIN VICTIMS AND ACCUSERS
AND WAS GETTING TO THE BOTTOM OF
WHAT NBC KNEW WHILE I WAS THERE.
AND THEN JUST INDEPENDENTLY.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT DID THEY
KNOW ABOUT MATT LAUER PRIOR TO
THE TIME THE WOMAN CAME FORWARD
WHO WAS ULTIMATELY HIS DOWNFALL?
SHE CAME FORWARD.
HER NAME IS BROOKE NEVILS.
MADE AN ALLEGATION AGAINST MATT
LAUER AND THE COMPANIES WHOLE
DEFENSE TO RONAN’S BOOK
ESSENTIALLY HAS BEEN THAT’S THE
FIRST WE KNEW ABOUT MATT LAUER.
THERE WAS NO DEAL BETWEEN US AND
HARVEY WEINSTEIN SO THAT HE
HARVEY WEINSTEIN TO COVER UP FOR
WOULDN’T REPORT ON MATT LAUER.
BECAUSE WE DIDN’T KNOW THAT MATT
LAUER WAS DOING THIS.
WE HAD NO NOTICE OF IT
WHATSOEVER.
>> Tucker: IS NOT A PLAUSIBLE
CLAIM?
>> IF THEY HAD NO SETTLEMENTS OF
ANY KIND AND NO COMPLAINTS ABOUT
MATT LAUER PRIOR TO BROOKE
NEVILS COMING FORWARD, SURE, IT
MIGHT BE.
BUT IS IT TRUE?
HERE IS WHAT THEY ARE SAYING.
NO SETTLEMENTS OF ANY KIND.
NO SETTLEMENTS.
THAT’S ILLEGAL SLEIGHT-OF-HAND.
YOU CAN GET PAID OUT AS A
SEXUAL-HARASSMENT VICTIM IN
SOMETHING OTHER THAN A
SETTLEMENT.
YOU CAN GET WHAT’S CALLED
ENHANCED SEVERANCE.
THAT’S THE SITUATION WHERE THE
RECEPTIONIST IS SUDDENLY GETTING
A SEVEN-FIGURE GOODBYE.
SHE WAS AN AMAZING TYPIST.
IT IS SEVERANCE.
IT’S NOT A SETTLEMENT.
BY THE WAY, IF YOU COULD BE
REALLY QUIET ABOUT NBC FOREVER
MORE, WE WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE
IT.
THAT’S WHAT WE NEED TO KNOW.
THEY HAVEN’T GOTTEN SPECIFIC
ABOUT WHAT MONIES WERE PAID OUT
TO HOME.
SHOW US THE MONEY.
THE NUMBER ONE THING THAT NEEDS
TO HAPPEN NOW IS THEY NEED TO
RELEASE ANY AND ALL MATT LAUER
ACCUSERS FROM THEIR
CONFIDENTIALITY AGREEMENTS.
NBC SAYS IT HAS NOTHING TO HIDE.
GREAT.
LET’S NOT HIDE ANYTHING.
SHOW US ALL OF THE AGREEMENTS,
THE ENHANCED SEVERANCE
AGREEMENTS REACHED OR AT LEAST
THE NUMBER SO WE CAN SEE WHICH
ONES POP OUT AND WHICH ONES ARE
SUPER HIGH.
ARE THEY ALL WOMEN?
DO THEY ALL HAVE A CONNECTION
WITH MATT LAUER?
RELEASE THE WOMEN FROM THEIR
CONFIDENTIALITY OBLIGATIONS.
>> Tucker: THIS PROBABLY WOULD
BE KNOWN RIGHT NOW IF THE
NETWORK HAD CONDUCTED AN
INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATION.
LAST SEPTEMBER, EARLY SEPTEMBER,
YOU ON YOUR SHOW ON THE AIR AND
NBC CALLED FOR AN INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATION INTO THESE
ALLEGATIONS.
TECHNICALLY HAVE THE TAPE OF YOU
DOING IT.
>> THERE’S A QUESTION ABOUT
WHETHER THERE SHOULD BE AN
OUTSIDE INVESTIGATOR TO TAKE A
HARD LOOK AT THIS.
BETWEEN THE INVESTIGATION NBC
DID INTERNALLY ON MATT LAUER TO
KNOW THIS, THERE’S A QUESTION OF
THE FAITH AND CONFIDENCE OF THE
PUBLIC AND THE REPORTING OF NBC
ON MATTERS INVOLVING ITSELF.
TO ME AS A LAWYER, IT’S JUST
ALWAYS BETTER IF YOU SEND IT
OUTSIDE.
THEN PEOPLE CAN HAVE MORE FAITH
IN IT AND IF THERE’S NOTHING TO
HIDE, YOU HAVE NO WORRIES ABOUT
EIGHT.
YOU HAVE NOTHING TO WORRY ABOUT.
>> Tucker: PEOPLE’S JAWS HUNG
OPEN WHEN HE SAID THAT.
THERE HAVE BEEN A COUPLE
PUBLISHED ACCOUNTS THAT SAY YOU
WERE FIRED FROM NBC A LITTLE
MORE THAN A MONTH LATER FOR
SAYING THAT.
IT’S THAT IN MIND, WITHOUT
HAVING YOU COMMENT ON IT, I WANT
TO GET YOUR RESPONSE ON
SOMETHING THAT AN ANCHOR AT
MSNBC DID TWO NIGHTS AGO.
CHRIS HAYES ADDRESSED THE
CREDIBILITY OF THE PRESIDENT OF
NBC NEWS DIRECTLY IN HER SHOW.
HE SAID THIS.
>> OPPENHEIMER AND OTHERS HAVE
MAINTAINED THE WEINSTEIN STORY
WAS NEVER BROADCAST BECAUSE IT
LACKED SUFFICIENT ON THE RECORDS
WERE SYNCED AFTER NBC SUPPORTED
RONAN FARROW’S ASSIGNMENT.
>> RONAN FARROW WALKED OUT OF
NBC NEWS AFTER WORKING ON THE
WEINSTEIN STORY AND WITHIN TWO
MONTHS PUBLISHED AN INCREDIBLE
ARTICLE AT THE NEW YORKER, THE
PATH OF LEAST RESISTANCE IS
ALWAYS THERE.
BECKONING SEDUCTIVELY WITH AN
ENTIRELY PLAUSIBLE COVER STORY.
YOU HAVE BIGGER FISH TO FRY.
THE STORY ISN’T READY.
THE IT’S THE EASE OF THE PATH
THAT MAKES IT THE ENEMY TO THE
KIND OF WORK IT WE AS
JOURNALISTS ARE SUPPOSED TO DO.
>> Tucker: HE IS SAYING
ESSENTIALLY WHAT YOU SAID.
HE DOESN’T TRUST THE MANAGEMENT
NBC NEWS.
GIVEN YOUR EXTREMES, DO YOU
THINK IS IN JEOPARDY OF BEING
FIRED?
>> NO COMMENT ON THAT.
I WILL SAY THE QUESTION IS OPEN
AS TO WHETHER THEY PUT DOLLARS
AHEAD OF DECENCY.
IF THEY WERE MORE INTERESTED IN
PROTECTING THEIR START ANCHOR
THEM PROTECTING THE WOMEN OF THE
COMPANY.
THERE NEEDS TO BE AN OUTSIDE
INVESTIGATION INTO THIS COMPANY.
THEY INVESTIGATED THEMSELVES.
THAT DOESN’T WORK.
FOX NEWS HAD AN OUTSIDE
INVESTIGATOR.
CBS NEWS HAD AN OUTSIDE
NPR, THE NFL.
THIS IS HOW IT’S DONE.
YOU GET SOMEBODY ON THE OUTSIDE
WHO CAN BE TRUSTED.
WHAT HAPPENED HERE IF YOU GOT
NOAH OPPENHEIMER WHO NOW THEY
ARE PULLING HIS COLLEGE WRITINGS
WERE HE SAID WOMEN LOVE TO BE
PRAYED ON.
APPARENTLY HE THINKS WOMEN LOVE
TO BE PREYED UPON.
NOAH HAS SAID THAT I DEEPLY
REGRET IT.
PEOPLE DO WRITE DOWN THINGS IN
COLLEGE.
AND THEY SAY DUMB THINGS.
TRUST ME.
BUT THAT’S THE PERSON WHO IS
INVESTIGATING.
ANDY LACK -- I’M SORRY, THE
REPORTING THAT RONAN HAS PUT OUT
IS THAT THERE IS AN ACCUSER, A
WOMAN NAMED JANE WALLACE WHO
SAID SHE WAS BULLIED OUT OF A
JOB AND WORKING FOR ANDY YEARS
AGO.
SHE HAD A CONSENSUAL AFFAIR WITH
HIM BUT THEN SHE SAYS SHE WAS
RETALIATED AGAINST.
SHE SAYS SHE SAYS HUMORLESSLY
PREYED ON FEMALE UNDERLINGS.
IF THESE HAVE PEOPLE OVERSEEING
THE INVESTIGATION INTO NBC.
THEY HAD THE GENERAL COUNSEL TO
THE INVESTIGATION.
HOW ARE PEOPLE SUPPOSED TO TRUST
IT?
THAT’S WHY HE GOT TO GET SOME AT
ANY OUTSIDE.
>> Tucker: THERE’S A STRIKING
IRONY.
EVEN AS THE MANAGEMENT OF NBC
CLEARLY IGNORED
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT AND ABUSE
WITHIN THEIR OWN BUILDING, THEY
SEEMED TO PUMP UP AND ABET WILD
AND UNSUBSTANTIATED ALLEGATIONS
OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT AGAINST
PEOPLE IN POLITICS THEY DON’T
LIKE.
I WATCHED YOU ON A PANEL AT NBC
WHEN YOU WORK THERE LAST YEAR ON
KAVANAUGH, THE LAST ARE YOU
COVERED.
SAVANNAH GUTHRIE, CHUCK TODD.
YOU ARE THE ONLY PERSON ON THE
PANEL WHO HELD OUT THE
POSSIBILITY THAT MAYBE
BRETT KAVANAUGH WAS NOT A RAPIST
BRETT KAVANAUGH WAS NOT A
RAPIST.
DID YOU FEEL LIKE THE ONLY
PERSON CAPABLE OF BEING
OBJECTIVE?
TO GO THERE’S NO QUESTION THAT
THE REPORTING THAT WAS DONE ON
NBC ON SOMEONE LIKE
JULIE SWETNICK, COMPLETELY
DISCREDITED ALLEGED THIRD
ACCUSER AGAINST KAVANAUGH.
A WOMAN WHOSE STORY HAD TONS OF
HOLES IN IT.
THERE WAS A DATE RAPE AND THEN
EVERYBODY SAW IT AND NOBODY
SIDE.
SHE IMPLODED ON THE AIR.
THEY WENT TO AIR WITH THAT
STORY.
WITH FAR LESS TREPIDATION THEN
THEY SHOWED GOING TO AIR ON THE
HARVEY WEINSTEIN STORY FOR WHICH
THEY HAD TAPES.
THEY HAD WITNESSES.
THEY HAD WOMEN ON THE RECORD.
ROSE McGOWAN WAS JUST ONE OF
THEM.
THERE IS A QUESTION OF WHY.
WAS IT POLITICAL, AS YOU
SUGGEST?
WAS IT SOMETHING ELSE?
WAS IT TO PROTECT SOMEBODY
INTERNALLY?
SOMEONE WHO WASN’T THE WOMEN OF
THE COMPANY.
WHAT RONAN IS SUGGESTING IS THEY
COVERED UP FOR ONE SEXUAL
PREDATOR, HARVEY WEINSTEIN, IN
ORDER TO PROTECT ANOTHER, MATT
LAUER.
THEY DENY ALL OF IT AND NBC HAS
PUT OUT SEVERAL STATEMENT SAYING
THAT RONAN IS A CONSPIRACY
THEORIST AND THIS IS ALL
NONSENSE AND HE’S GOT AN AX TO
GRIND.
BUT IF THAT’S TRUE AND THERE’S
NOTHING TO
>> Tucker: WELCOME BACK.
MEGYN KELLY HASN’T BEEN ON TV
FOR YEARS AND SHE HAS A LOT TO
SAY.
WE HAVE ARE HERE TONIGHT.
THANKS TO RONAN FARROW WE’VE
LEARNED ABOUT THE LINKS SOME NBC
EXECUTIVES WENT TO COVER UP
SEXUAL ABUSE.
THE DETAILS ARE STUNNING.
EVEN SOME ON THE LEFT,
PRESUMABLY NBC VIEWERS
THEMSELVES, HAVE EXPRESSED
OUTRAGE.
THE FEMINIST GROUP ULTRA VIOLET
SAID "THE DNC NEEDS TO MAKE IT
CLEAR THEY SUPPORT SURVIVORS OF
SEXUAL ABUSE AND CANCEL THE
UPCOMING 2020 DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENT PRIMARY DEBATE ON
MSNBC UNTIL COMCAST AND NBC NEWS
TAKE CLEAR STEPS TO CLEAN UP THE
TOXIC CULTURE THAT EXIST ACROSS
THEIR NETWORK."
MEGYN KELLY, DO YOU THINK
THERE’S ANY CHANCE THE DNC WILL
ACT ON IT?
>> I DO THINK THERE’S A CHANCE.
I DO.
IF THIS WERE FOX NEWS AND
FOX NEWS WERE HOSTING A
DEMOCRATIC DEBATE IN CONJUNCTION
WITH "THE WASHINGTON POST," THEY
WOULD BE PUTTING ON THE
FULL-COURT PRESS TO MAKE SURE
FOX MADE SOME SORT OF PROMISE TO
CLEAN UP ITS ACT.
SO I THINK -- I TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY.
PEOPLE ARE NOT SCREWING AROUND
ANYMORE WHEN IT COMES TO THE
TREATMENT OF WOMEN.
WHAT USED TO BE TOLERATED WILL
NOT BE TOLERATED ANYMORE.
IT’S NOT THAT WE HAVE A PERFECT
CULTURE LIKE THAT WHEN WE
RECOGNIZE THERE’S A PROBLEM.
IS THAT COMPANIES ARE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME CLEAN,
INVESTIGATE WITH THE PROBLEMS
ARE, AND COME UP WITH
RESOLUTIONS.
NBC SAYS IT’S DONE THAT.
THEY SAY YOU CAN TRUST THE
INTERNAL GC.
RONAN HAS GIVEN US 400 REASONS
TO DOUBT IT.
IT’S REALLY UP TO THE PUBLIC.
ARE THEY GOING TO PUT THE
PRESSURE ON THEM TO DO
SOMETHING, GET AN OUTSIDE
INVESTIGATOR, OR AREN’T THEY?
>> Tucker: ONE OF THE MOST
AMAZING I THINK DETAILS, MAYBE
NOT SO SURPRISING, THAT
HILLARY CLINTON APPLIED PRESSURE
TO FARROW, HE SAYS, NOT TO
PURSUE THE HARVEY WEINSTEIN
STORY.
SO I WONDER AND OF COURSE I
DON’T KNOW THE TRUTH.
THAT’S HIS CLAIM.
WHY HASN’T ANYONE ASKED
HILLARY CLINTON ABOUT IT?
>> IF HE EVENTUALLY THEY WILL.
THERE’S A LOT OF FISH TO FRY
THERE.
I THINK HILLARY SPOKES VISION
IS, IT SAID IT WAS NOTHING AND
IT’S BEEN MISSED OR PRESENTED.
WE ARE KIND OF DENYING IT.
MORE NEEDS TO HAPPEN IN ORDER
FOR US TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
IT.
NBC SAYS THERE IS NO WAY FOR
THEM TO KNOW ANY OF IT.
BECAUSE THEY DIDN’T KNOW
ANYTHING UNTIL BROOKE NEVILS
CAME IN AND ONLY THAT POINTED A
COUPLE MORE WOMEN COME FORWARD
AND SAY ME TOO.
THE TRUTH IS WE’VE SEEN ALREADY
THERE WAS A WOMAN, I HAD HER ON
MY SHOW I WAS AT NBC, SHE HAD A
CONSENSUAL AFFAIR WITH FLOUR.
HE WAS -- HE PLUCKED HER OUT OF
BEING A P.A.
BROOKE NEVILS, 30 YEARS OLD,
ASSISTANT TO MEREDITH VIEIRA,
SAME THING.
THE MULTIPLE WAYS OF -- SHE SAYS
SHE WAS RAPED BY HIM.
HE HAS DENIED IT AND SAID IT WAS
CONSENSUAL.
ANOTHER WOMAN WHO SAID SHE
EXPOSED HIMSELF TO HER AFTER A
PARTY AND THAT SHE ULTIMATELY
LEFT THE COMPANY.
THERE’S A WOMAN WHO CLAIMED SHE
HAD SEX WITH HIM IN HIS OFFICE
AND SHE FAINTED IT WAS SO
DRAMATIC.
THE QUESTION IS IF THEY DIDN’T
KNOW, WHY DIDN’T THEY KNOW?
>> Tucker: THEY ARE LYING.
IT DOESN’T DIMINISH THE
SELF-RIGHTEOUSNESS WITH WHICH
THEY APPROACH OTHER PEOPLE
SINCE.
I WANT TO ASK YOU.
YOU WORKED HERE AT FOX NEWS AND
YOU WERE TO NBC.
YOU’VE GOT SOME PERSPECTIVE.
I WANT TO ASK ABOUT THE STATE OF
JOURNALISM TODAY AND I WANT TO
START WITH A CLIP FROM LAST
NIGHTS DEBATE.
THIS WAS ANDERSON COOPER AT CNN
ASKING A QUESTION OF THE FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN.
WATCH THIS.
>> THE IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY
CENTERED ON PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
ATTEMPTS TO GET POLITICAL DIRT
FROM UKRAINE ON VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN AND HIS SON, HUNTER.
MR. VICE PRESIDENT,
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS FALSELY
ACCUSED YOUR SON OF DOING
SOMETHING WRONG WHILE SERVING IN
A COMPANY BORN IN UKRAINE.
I WANT TO POINT OUT THERE’S NO
EVIDENCE OF WRONGDOING BY EITHER
ONE OF YOU.
>> Tucker: SO WHAT KIND OF
JOURNALIST BEGINS A QUESTION TO
A POLITICIAN BY REASSURING HIM
THAT ATTACKS BY HIS OPPONENTS
ARE FALSE AND THAT HE’S
INNOCENT.
IS THAT A QUESTION?
>> THE ANSWER WAS BAKED INTO THE
QUESTION.
IT’S CLEAR YOU DID NOTHING WRONG
BUT DID YOU DO ANYTHING WRONG?
THAT WASN’T ANDERSON’S BEST
MOMENT.
I LIKE ANDERSON.
IT WASN’T HIS BEST MOMENT.
IT WOULD’VE BEEN FINE IF HE
WOULD’VE SAID YOU DIDN’T DO
ANYTHING ILLEGAL.
NO ONE HAS ALLEGED YOU DID
BECAUSE REALLY WHAT THE GUY DID
HE SAT ON THE BOARD AND HUNTER
BIDEN HAS NO EXPERTISE IN
UKRAINE.
HE HAS NO EXPERTISE ON NATURAL
GAS.
HE TAKES HIS JOB SITTING ON THE
BOARD OF THIS UKRAINIAN COMPANY
50,000 BUCKS A MONTH WHILE HIS
DAD IS THE VICE PRESIDENT.
THE REASON HE GOT THE JOB IS
PRESUMABLY HIS LAST NAME IS
BIDEN.
SO THEY ARE PAYING FOR ACCESS.
THEY ARE PAYING FOR THE
ASSOCIATION.
IS THAT CORRUPT?
YOU CAN MAKE A VERY STRONG
ARGUMENT THAT IT IS.
IS IT WRONG?
THAT IS UP TO THE VOTERS TO
DECIDE.
MAYBE HE WOULD LIKE IT BACK.
MAYBE HE COULD HAVE REWORDED IT.
>> Tucker: I AGREE WITH YOU,
BY THE WAY.
I KNOW ANDERSON COOPER FAIRLY
WELL.
I DON’T THINK HE’S THE WORST
OFFENDER.
BUT THIS IS PART OF A LARGER
TAPESTRY HERE AND IT ADDS UP TO
BASICALLY PARTISAN INTERFERENCE
IN AN ELECTION.
YOU HAVE JOURNALISTS WHO FEEL
THAT THEIR FIRST OBLIGATION IS
TO HELP A CANDIDATE OR HURT
ANOTHER CANDIDATE.
THAT’S NOT JOURNALISM.
>> 100%.
THIS GOES BACK TO BEFORE TRUMP
WAS ELECTED.
JORGE RAMOS OF UNIVISION CAME ON
MY SHOW AND WE HAD A VERY
HEARTFELT DISCUSSION ABOUT
JOURNALISM IN AMERICA AND HE
MADE A STRONG PLEA FOR
JOURNALISTS TO ABANDON
NEUTRALITY.
HE SAID IT’S OVER.
YOU’VE GOT TO COME OUT AND
YOU’VE GOT TO SAY TRUMP IS A
RACIST.
TRUMP IS A MISOGYNIST.
TRUMP IS A BIGOT.
WHATEVER YOUR VIEW IS, YOU’VE
GOT TO SAY IT AND SELL IT.
THE TIME FOR NEUTRALITY HAS
PASSED.
I DO BELIEVE HE’S PERSUADED AND
OTHERS HAVE COME TO THEIR OWN
CONCLUSION THAT THAT’S THE WAY
FORWARD.
THAT’S ALL WE HAD A QUESTION --
THERE WAS ANOTHER CNN DEBATE
WHERE DON LEMMONS PHYSICALLY
SAID HOW DO YOU ANSWER VOTERS
WHO PRIORITIZE THE ECONOMY
OVERCOMES BIGOTRY.
THERE’S A JUDGMENT IN THERE.
I’M SAYING FINE, MANY PEOPLE MAY
AGREE WITH THAT.
IT IS THE ANCHORS’ SUBJECTIVE
JUDGMENT AND IT DOESN’T BELONG,
IN MY VIEW, IN A DEBATE
QUESTION.
"NEW YORK TIMES" IS ARGUING
ABOUT WHETHER THE TIMES SHOULD
BE "PART OF THE RESISTANCE."
>> Tucker: THE PROBLEM I HAVE
IS NOT THAT SOMEONE SHOWS AN
OPINION.
IF THAT THEY ARE LYING ABOUT
WHERE JOURNALISTS BARELY
WHAT IT DOES AND THEY ARE SAYING
OBJECTIVE.
WHY CAN’T THEY DROP THE PRETENSE
AND BE HONEST AND SAY THAT WE
ARE PARTISAN COMBATANTS.
>> WE ALREADY KNOW.
THAT’S A REAL JOKE.
WE ALREADY KNOW.
FOX NEWS WAS FOUNDED IN 1996.
THEY HAD THEIR BIRTHDAY.
THE PREMISE THAT THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE STORIES WEREN’T BEING
TOLD OF THAT HALF THE COUNTRY
WAS BEING IGNORED AND THAT IF
YOU DID FAIR AND BALANCED NEWS,
THE PEOPLE WOULD WATCH.
THERE WAS A PREMISE THAT THE
OTHER MEDIA, THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA, MAYBE THEY WEREN’T FAR
LEFT BUT THAT THERE WAS A BAKED
IN BIAS AGAINST PEOPLE WHO
BELIEVE IN HOMESCHOOLING, WHO
BELIEVE IN A PRO-LIFE POSITION,
WHO MIGHT HAVE A GUN.
SO THEY MADE A WHOLE EMPIRE
BASED ON PROGRAMMING TO THOSE
PEOPLE.
WHAT HAPPENED NOW ON THE OTHER
HALF OF THE COUNTRY, IN THE
MAINSTREAM, THEY HAVE EMBRACED
IT.
IT WAS SORT OF PASSIVE AND NOW
NOW IT’S LESS WORK.
HE IS TOO BAD.
WE HAVE TO WORK TOGETHER.
WILL BE JUDGED.
HISTORY WILL JUDGE WHETHER WE
WERE FOR OR AGAINST THIS MAN.
>> Tucker: WE WERE PLANNING TO
BRING A DENNIS RODMAN SEGMENT.
WILL
>> Tucker: WELCOME BACK.
WE PROMISED YOU A CONVERSATION
WITH DENNIS RODMAN ON CHINA IN
THE SEGMENT WE GOT CARRIED AWAY
TALKING TO MEGYN KELLY SO WERE
GOING TO CONTINUE THAT.
WE WILL BRING IT TO YOU
TOMORROW.
>> RODMAN IS A GREAT INTERVIEW.
>> Tucker: YOU’VE TAKEN A YEAR
OFF AND YOU BEEN THINKING,
ASSESSING, PROBABLY WATCHING
NEWS.
>> A LITTLE.
>> Tucker: TWO DAYS AGO, THIS
REPORT COMES OUT FROM PROJECT
VERITAS AND CNN AND IN IT,
WHATEVER YOU THINK OF THEIR
METHODS, THEY HAVE THE HEAD OF
CNN, JEFF ZUCKER INSTRUCTING HIS
EMPLOYEES IMPEACHMENT,
IMPEACHMENT, IMPEACHMENT.
HITTING IMPEACHMENT NO MATTER
WHAT.
IMPEACHMENT IS THE ONLY STORY
THAT MATTERS.
SOUNDS MORE LIKE A POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN THAN A NEWS JUDGMENT.
>> IMPEACHMENT IS A BIG STORY.
IF THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS GOING TO GET
IMPEACHED AND POSSIBLY BOUNCED
OUT OF OFFICE, IT’S A MAJOR
STORY.
I THINK IT’S DEFENSIBLE ON THE
PART OF JEFF ZUCKER BUT I THING
THE HYPERFOCUS ON A BUY MOST
MEDIA AT THE EXTENT OF ALL ELSE
IS NOT NEW.
SINCE THE DAY TRUMP GOT INTO
OFFICE, THEY HAVE BEEN
HYPERFOCUS ON IMPEACHMENT.
THIS IS ONE OF THE PROBLEMS THE
DEMOCRATS AND ALSO TO SOME
EXTENT THE MEDIA IS UP AGAINST.
THAT FROM THE DAY HE TOOK
OFFICE, IT WAS THE 25TH
AMENDMENT, THE MULLINGS CLAUSE,
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA,
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
ALL THOSE THINGS.
HE HAS TO BE IMPEACHED.
IF EVERYTHING IS AND 11, NOTHING
IS AND 11.
THEY HAVE MAY BE STUMBLED ON AN
11.
THEY HAVE THE TRANSCRIPT.
TRUMP SAID IT WAS A PERFECT
CALL.
YOU CAN MAKE AN ARGUMENT.
NO ONE IS PAYING AS MUCH
ATTENTION AS THEY OTHERWISE
WOULD HAVE IF WE HADN’T BEEN
TOLD FROM THE BEGINNING THAT HE
NEEDS TO BE BOUNCED OUT OF
OFFICE.
SO I DON’T KNOW.
THEY CAN RATCHET UP THE COVERED
ALL THEY WANT.
I DON’T KNOW WHETHER THEY ARE
CONVINCING EVERYONE ON THE FENCE
OR IN THE MIDDLE.
>> Tucker: AT ALL.
IT SEEMS LIKE PEOPLE ARE
STARTING TO TUNE OUT IN GENERAL
FROM NEWS COVERAGE BECAUSE, LIKE
HOW LONG CAN YOU KEEP --
>> OUR OUTRAGE CULTURE.
WATCH ON MY SUPPOSED TO BE
OUTRAGED ABOUT?
I’M GOING TO GET OUTRAGED.
JUST GIVE ME TWO SECONDS.
UKRAINE, ALL RIGHT.
>> Tucker: WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS AT THE TIME.
AT TRUMP’S ELECTION, YOU HEARD
PEOPLE SAY WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT WHO IS VOTERS ARE.
THERE’S A WHOLE WORLD WE KNOW
NOTHING ABOUT.
WE SHOULD BE SYMPATHETIC TO THE
TRUMP VOTERS.
THAT LASTED FOR ABOUT 15 SECONDS
THAT LASTED FOR ABOUT 15
SECONDS.
>> YOU’RE WRONG.
THEY LOOKED AND THERE WERE LIKE
NEVER MIND!
I THINK IT WAS A CONSCIOUS
DECISION THAT WE DON’T WANT TO
GO INTO THAT WORLD.
LOOK AT THEM WITH THEIR GUNS IN
THEIR COWBOY HATS.
NO.
I DON’T THINK THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA HAS ANY CONNECTION OF
FLYOVER COUNTRY AND WHEN THEY
MEANDER THROUGH MONTANA, THEY
HAVE NEVER SEEN SUCH A THING.
IT’S A RODEO AND THEY TALKED
DIFFERENTLY.
THEY HAVE DIFFERENT VALUES.
>> Tucker: SHOULDN’T THEY WANT
TO UNDERSTAND THE COUNTRY THEY
COVER?
>> I THINK THEY THINK THEY DO.
I THINK THEY BELIEVE THEY DO.
BUT I THINK MOST PEOPLE, FOR
EXAMPLE, TAKE A LOOK AT THE GUY
IN WASHINGTON STATE WHO WOULDN’T
BAKE THE CAKE FOR THE GAY COUPLE
AND THEY JUST THINK BIGOT.
BIGOT.
>> Tucker: THE MEDIA.
>> THE PROBLEM IS IT SO MUCH
MORE COMPLETED THAN THAT.
>> Tucker: THAT’S FOR SURE.
I HAVE TO ASK YOU, SINCE YOU HAD
THIS VERY WELL COVERED CAREER
AND YOU’VE TAKEN A YEAR TO
THINK, WHAT HAVE YOU LEARNED
AFTER ALL OF IT?
EVERYTHING THAT’S HAPPENED.
>> VERY LITTLE.
I DON’T LEARN SO WELL.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
>> I AM LIKE WOODY ALLEN.
I AM 48 YEARS OLD AND I’VE
LEARNED NOTHING.
NO.
I HAVE LEARNED A THING OR TWO.
WHAT COMES TO MIND IS THE
GOODNESS OF HUMANITY.
THE KINDNESS OF STRANGERS.
AS AWFUL AS THE MEDIA CAN BE,
ACTUAL HUMANS ARE AWESOME AND
LOVING AND KIND AND HELPFUL.
I THINK ABOUT IT BECAUSE I LEFT
FOX NEWS IN JANUARY OF ’17 AND
THE REASON I LEFT IS BECAUSE I
WANTED TO BE WITH MY FAMILY.
I WAS MISSING MY KIDS’
CHILDHOOD.
THEY WERE LITTLE.
7, 5, 3.
I COULD STILL SEE IT AND BE PART
OF IT.
NOW I’M DOING IT.
I’VE SPENT THE PAST YEAR IN
PARTICULAR BUT EVEN BEFORE THAT,
WITH THEM AND I AM MOTHERING MY
OWN KIDS.
THERE IS NO SUBSTITUTE FOR THAT.
I LOST MY DAD WHEN I WAS
15 YEARS OLD, AND SO I KNOW, I
KNOW ON AN INHERENT BASIS.
YOU DON’T GET A DO OVER.
I’M THERE AND I’M ENJOYING IT.
I WILL GET BACK ON THE WAR SOON.
THIS HAS BEEN FUN.